all right Jacqueline yeah
Jacqueline where you from originally
where'd you grow up I'm from California
I'm from LA I grew up in um in
south-central but I had furniture going
to school and that was very ease because
of my family's background um I was in
between my grandpa and my mom back and
forth and my grandfather was a retired
LAPD for Parker center a homicide
detective and he's my everything you
know how I world and tell me what your
family you grew up with both of your
parents um I don't know my father my mom
had me when she was 12 years old well 12
yeah she had me when she was 12 my mom
was a hard worker she went to work every
day to support her four children yeah
and um she met my stepfather and
everything went down the drain because
he was a drug dealer he he sold every
drug that can be named in LA he so how
was your childhood generally my
childhood when I was at my grandpa
it was very healthy
I hated it I'd rather be in the street
at home really well first trick I ever
turned was not big a rollup yeah to feed
my brothers and sisters but I had to
beat them because um my step father and
my mom they were out selling drugs
what a trick what is that um well my
stepfather mom go behind my stepfather I
don't know my mom she fell in love with
a thug it was terrible
but she wasn't brought up that way and
my mom allowed him to sell me to his
dope dealer and you know he used to
molest me my mom goes working to make
you know having me
suck his dick and promise me that you
wouldn't do it no more but he would
every time my mom will work I hate him I
I didn't have a childhood you know I had
to grow up early and life was okay with
your stepdads and stuff like that my
stepfather I disliked him because he
took something from me and he put a
price on it a price on he sold me to his
dope doing because his dope dealer
wander a virgin so he sold that he sold
me to him I were rich most ten years old
whereas verses I can talk to is my um my
grandpa I told I told him everything
yeah back in eighty Hollywood used to be
way out yeah and it was like the
glamorous thing that got caught up with
this guy named lucky because I was a
runaway they took me to a foster home
and he put me in a foster home I met
this girl there and she took me to him
and it was like he was handsome and I'm
one day I wanted to go home and him and
his main girl beat me up really bad
don't want to go home because I miss my
family yeah
and so trick picked me up and he took me
home I told my grandpa what happened
what's his temp did to me and you know
he got arrested he got um it's prison
for 20 years for pimping and pandering
minor but my pup my grandpa he was my
help there's nobody else would get
involved but I shouldn't everybody
everyone got word that I told you no I
have no problems I was tense ever again
so I've been to prison I've been shot
chillin ciaw and this time I got clean I
gave one year in a program assist the
Alliance and I finally got I graduated
and I was so happy because I had coppers
something for myself
it was awesome I wanted to do that
wasn't forced to do it and I did it
because I wanted to but I haven't got no
police contact since 2010 and I did that
yeah on my own hmm what year were you
and you first started using crack I
started doing crack 19 the day that they
found Tom Bradley starter in the park
and she was dead that was 1994 he shut
the whole park yeah because they found
Tom Reilly's daughter in her trunk of
her car
yeah and how old were you mmm I see I
was about about 30 maybe 32 I don't
remember so you didn't start using crack
until much later and I was doing crystal
meth even yeah goddamnit
yeah that's the first road I did there
what age and
I'll say 17 yeah I met Moloch Jennifer
her name and she took that she took it
on the runaways
but she was awesome lady that was safe
haven for us yeah you're from our age I
say 11 tracks gingers took me in showed
me the ropes of the streets and I thank
God that someone taught me something
well that's right the pimp I didn't want
to be bothered with nothin I ain't got
one champ in my entire life
my grandpa's told me a pimp doesn't like
level prostitute he just loves what
she's given him once your dad gone he
moves on to the next and that's a true
statement he doesn't care about you he
cares about the money once you're dead
God he moves on how long were you with
them I sneaked up about a month but
what's in that month I sold so much ass
that might I was a young girl nicely
beautiful and you know burn across some
people your self-esteem goes down I
already had low self-esteem anyway but
you know this world can make you make
you feel this high and down here that
really can do that because never gained
fame ever I think that's the most stupid
thing in the whole wide world
I guess there's something I don't
believe in
it's not cool do you have kids of Europe
have four have beautiful children
they're bilingual they're dadaism
Salvadorian did you raise them know who
raised I got paid to have those kids
only kid that I had because I wanted to
as my youngest son his name is autumn
mm-hmm he's beautiful
that's the only kid of one in the other
three I got paid to have yeah
and they were in Minneapolis now with
her with their dad
and you're living on Skid Row now yeah I
lived like two blocks away but I'm
leaving there because the person I stay
with I don't have sex with him so he
wants me to leave are you staying in
Lorraine hotel and that Hotel ruined and
took everything I owned but I lost
everything I lost the phone that
happened my dead mom my mom was deceased
now she's got killed on Thanksgiving Day
of 84 my mom and aunt the person that
killed them did not do one day in jail
that's when olympics came to LA heard
your mom he shot my mom my aunt three
times I shot my mom wants this in the
newspaper it was enough Sanford said
Virginia newspaper on Thanksgiving Day
and I miss my mom a lot but I lost the
phone there that had a picture of my mom
she's 12 years old and tons of bones
wrong I seen my mom and I made my day
every time that phone wrong I never been
my mom's burial ground
or you thought no birds that it's here
somewhere I don't know where that though
I've got some tissues nurse is ready you
lose your mommy lost everything that's
important I think because there's a lot
of youngsters down here they have no
respect
except your mom the way you are because
she loves you she she accepts them but
one wish I wish I could be with my mom
just for boys she had you know she'd
make a wish 24 hours we'll hang out with
one another my mom worked for the SPCA
so she taught me a lot about animals I
love animals
yeah so even the fact that your mom sold
you out
you still would love to see I never yeah
I forgive her you know you have to
forgive to be you know blessed got to no
matter what my mom made mistakes she
wasn't perfect but she taught me to love
animals
I'm very good animals I love animals of
all nature yeah so Jaclyn what are you
doing for money now you still you still
regards well being honest when I need
money I get exercise so I get almost
$1,000 a month but because of my crack
habit it goes and I need help but I need
a program I really do because I can't do
it on my own I can't
two little mountain and I was looking
program and I was stay
I need that I'm gonna die out here the
streets
[Music]
I know I know that I'm going to die one
day I'm gonna die real food and stage
four of renal failure yeah
and this is what streets done me all
right then to myself yeah yeah let me
stroke it out it takes a toll on my
kidneys that's probably why I'm drop and
weight so much but I don't get somewhere
and get help
yeah will she go on dialysis that's a
done deal
do you think your childhood traumas kind
of set you up for your smart style I try
to commit suicide I set myself on fire I
try to take myself out and it didn't
work it work there's one reason why I
get SSI because I try to hurt myself
sometimes you know sometimes if you're
dead you're better off
I seen a lot of people get bodies that
I'd never was exposed to but I'd seen
these youngsters beat up older people
and literally kill them and it's like
that's somebody's grandpa or father but
they don't care don't care so I try to
just do me you know I do me
I'm very kind of everybody I don't like
fighting I have problem going on with
myself I don't need to be and I I
excused myself from the problems I walk
away because - right don't make it wrong
those junk stirs from great Street
they're really mean really mean I'll say
Julie they robbed you to take your money
and you know people work hard for what
they have and if you don't respect your
elders you're not gonna have long life
what was the first time you were taking
advantage of sexually that my stepfather
stepped out there what agent and you had
him up the tits yet I got played by my
stepfather and you know my mom took me
Hostel epoxy 'ls I had an abortion or
did you I don't remember but I was very
young I think I was like ten maybe nine
years old I was pregnant by my
stepfather I know I know
what was wrong but I know I'll kept
throwing up and my mom had me checked by
the you know the kid doctor I should go
I was having sex and everything
and she had you know she have checked me
to see was I have an end of course he's
my I felt kind of doctor and they called
them a pediatrician yeah pediatrician
told my mom I was having sex what was
your mom's reaction to finding out that
her husband would believe me because my
grandfather put that man in jail and my
mom told the cop that it wasn't true
wasn't true when you got put up I mean
he got free but I wouldn't lie my
grandpa about nothing nothing at all huh
so my grandpa was my everything because
I can talk to him and tell him
everything
he loved me no matter what and he would
always tell me that no matter what I
love you love me the bad choices I made
him like but he still cared and
everything my trombone tell me it come
to pass everything yeah everything I
listen to my grandpa yeah that's my
guardian angel I think
I'm out here alone walking around yeah
that's my mom and my grandpa's my
guardian angel my instincts talk I
listen because all money's not good
money in every car that glitters is not
gold you know and a lot of girls have
gotten cars on this street here and
never came back
yeah so your instincts will never lead
you wrong and everyone has instinct if
your animal you know animal to teach you
a lot about instinct especially cats
because they can see they have a spirit
they can see things are not the human
can't see animals have that good
instinct
either a lot from animals do you do you
have anybody in your life in your family
I have family but my family well my
brother he works at up and now do at the
country vip-only even their security for
a long time I have found that and I have
family in Palm Springs
but I don't see my family's so bad it
was lost everything I owned in the rain
all their numbers and everything but I
lost
and we go we just hug my family tire the
streets these streets don't love me all
your years of working as a prostitute
would his terrible things happen to you
yeah yeah it has
I've had men I do what they ask me to do
and I have them going out the door they
come behind me and grab me back in the
room and they they won one guy he just
got a prison his friend
it was terrible he told me he's gonna do
me like Jeffrey Dahmer did his victims
and he did some bad things to those
people and I just went to sleep and I
wake up to is all over but he left me in
the hotel but holding that get they took
everything to a value of mine they
trapped me like [ __ ] yeah I'm lucky I
woke up though because they could have
killed me and kept going
yeah I was out there when the hill
strangler was out that's my first time
ever running away from home when he'll
strangler was out my mom worried so much
for me because every time somebody came
on the news she she prayed wasn't me the
hillside that's the first time yeah and
I was like in the early 80s wasn't it
and he was they were in Hollywood and
they were picking up girls
my mom prayed that it wasn't me when
they wasn't yelps yeah what do you think
it is that makes that lifestyle okay
perfect for a woman well that my selves
not okay but it's the oldest profession
there is a sexist old every day in
different ways or exactly thank you so
much I'm talking to me nice
thank you - thanks for coming in
you